has caused a series of failures and so
one of the things safety experts have
tried to do is reduce the
interconnectedness so you don't get that
domino effect and in the case of the
financial system one thing they've tried
to do is impose one that when they
investigated some of these complex
financial intuition institutions they
would find they have like six thousand
legal subsidiaries right and that their
Cayman Island subsidiary was the one
that was actually entering into these
derivatives contracts with somebody
else's Cayman Island subsidiary and
nobody really knew who's gonna be like
responsible if like one of those
contracts went bad so they're imposing
the so-called living will requirement on
large banks so they actually have to
explain how they would be taken through
a bankruptcy and how all these
subsidiaries would be shrunk and
interestingly enough bankers are
discovering that a lot of these
subsidiaries are in fact unnecessary and
they're then cells are pursuing a
simpler structure and hopefully that
will reduce some of these chain reaction
type failures that yeah we've just
talked about let's do one one more
question okay
a fascinating talk and of course part of
a large literature that I'm sure you
know very very well in the search the
surprising thing to me is you know FDA
FDR when F when Federal Deposit
Insurance was introduced was querulous
he said this will make banks act
irresponsibly but we never seem to
revisit those disconnection of the risk
system we we not disconnected we
disconnects Pandit from 2002 essentially
an infinite amount of deposit insurance
today and we added on all the insurance
for federal for Fannie and Freddie and
then all the other things effectively we
promoted the moral hazard problem that
the insurance system was supposed to
resolve wouldn't it be it's sort of
surprising we've never revisited any of
those he we tried with flood insurance
we try it a little bit with fire stuff
but in both cases it was rolled back
because nobody could articulate the
safety reasons in the ration reasons for
reforming those systems do you see any
hope in reform we've talked about the
psychological factor the political
factor well first of all I would
actually provide a slightly different
interpretation of what's happening since
the 1930s and you're absolutely right
FDR was very worried about the moral
hazard consequences of Deposit Insurance
but there was a very strong absurd of
feeling in Congress that this had to be
done and so it happened anyway but there
because of the recognition of moral
hazard with Deposit Insurance came a
much more vigorous system of federal
oversight of these banks now we can
argue about whether that was a good
thing because a mint banks couldn't do
certain things and for example it
actually deprived a lot of people of
credit because regulated banks couldn't
make certain loans that were deemed too
risky but what happened interesting
along the way is that because people
wanted types of loans and the banks
weren't providing it is that this
wonderful innovative Society we have
created alternatives and that is how the
what we now call the shadow banks came
about in the early 1980s in 1990s as I
was talking about as these restrictions
tightened on the on the banks we saw the
creation of a lot of financial company
lenders like household finance like
countrywide
and what their model is that they would
originate the mortgage but because they
did not have the deposit base to fund
that mortgage permanently they would put
them into a mortgage-backed security and
sell that to private investors and
everybody said this is great
this is really good this is not only
protecting banks because they're not the
ones making the mortgages it's actually
defusing risk throughout the financial
system instead of like one bank in North
Dakota or Massachusetts or Texas being
exposed to only mortgages and
Massachusetts or Texas an investor a
Chinese investor can buy a
mortgage-backed security and have
exposure to mortgage from all around the
country
so in this perverse way these efforts to
make the banking system safer cause the
risk to migrate outwards and because
people falsely believed that while
actually they it was true for a while
that that made the system safer but it
actually I'm you know unleashed an
enormous supply of credit some of the
channel through Fannie and Freddie that
enabled a housing bubble to happen that
might not have happened in a system that
had not allowed the risk to migrate out
of the banking system so that was my
first point is that I I interpret things
a little bit differently but where I
completely agree with you is that the
rescues and the bailouts of 2008 and
2009 have convey today new aura of too
big to fail around big institutions and
you could see this in the pricing of
their debt they could systematically
borrow at lower prices than smaller
institutions that everybody knew could
be allowed to fail so one of the
priorities in this period is to squeeze
out that too-big-to-fail premium and one
of the ways to do it as I was talking
that was to force and hold more capital
so they're less likely to fail that
makes them less profitable and
shareholders will therefore discourage
banks from getting big and being subject
to those rules but the other thing is to
make it as clear as possible that they
can be allowed to fail and as I said I
don't think we'll be able to prove we've
succeeded until something actually
happens I'm not sure I want to be around
when it happens I mean nobody really
knows what will happen but if you
actually watch the pricing of their
bonds they are slowly converging on the
price that the higher boring rates that
smaller banks have to fail the rating
agencies have started to take away the
benefit of too big to fail from the
raise of
signing these banks we haven't succeeded
yet but I do believe we're going in the
right direction Craig thank you for
coming back well thank you David it's
been great thanks for having me thanks
Ivan you it last year last year there's
there's some books out there if you want
to buy them and hang around for a few
minutes if you want to talk thanks a lot
you're watching book TV on c-span -
television for serious readers here's a
look at what's on prime-time tonight we
kick off the evening with david reef who
questions if ending extreme poverty and
hunger around the world is possible then
at 8:15 University of Wisconsin's
Jennifer Ratner Rosen Hagin highlights
the life and career of Friedrich
Nietzsche followed by Steven salaita at
8:45 p.m. Eastern
his book is uncivil writes Palestine and
the limits of academic freedom and at
ten on afterwards criminologist Barry
Lazar talks about violent crime in
America we finish up our primetime
programming at 11:00 with a history of
autism that all happens tonight on
c-span 2's book TV and first up on book
TV in primetime it's david reef
good evening and welcome to mid
Manhattan library please take a moment
to silence your cellphone's if they're
on this event is being taped by c-span
and book TV during the Q&A portion just
so you know the microphone will be there
microphone and it will not project into
this room so please speak loudly and
clearly tonight's program is a talk
based on the book reproach of hunger
food justice and money in the 21st
century by David Reath the war on
worldwide hunger recently thought to be
thought by leading intellectuals to be
winnable is called into question in
David Rives new book hmm here Rieff
discusses complex factors that are
possibly pushing the goal of eradicating
hunger out of reach the rise in the
price of food staples in the world
market the practice of using corn to
make ethanol based fuels instead of food
the global warming and it's resulting
extreme weather patterns creating severe
droughts particularly in Africa and
increased meat consumption in China and
India which reduces the supply of grain
for direct consumption by people the
reproach of hunger received a starred
review in Publishers Weekly which stated
that it is a stellar addition to the
Canon of development policy literature
david reef is a political analyst
journalist and cultural critic he
graduated with a degree in history from
Princeton University his books have
focused on immigration international
conflict and humanitarian
humanitarianism he is the author of
eight previous books and the member of
New York Institute for the Humanities
has collaborated as an editor with the
world policy journal the New Republic
and Harper's Magazine he is written for
New York Times Magazine in Los Angeles
Times Book Review additionally he is the
founder of the war crimes project at the
American University in Washington DC
please give a warm welcome to mr. David
Rhee
[Applause]
thank you very much thank you for above
all for coming out in the unspeakable
whether global warming or no global
warming it seems we will get a little
bit of winter
even if sort of at the wrong time and in
the strange places I it's always I'm
very old now but it even so it is made a
slight turn to see myself describe it as
always feels like an obituary to me and
but in fact I have been doing this for a
very long time I started writing about
migration in the US I wrote two books
about Miami just for those of you who
don't know what I my work and one about
Los Angeles and about sort of the
transformations that the great
emigration has wrought I did this in the
80s in early 90s I wrote for taking
about I was very interested in Cuban
Americans so I wrote a book about them
as well and have some connections to
that world and then I became sort of
slightly by accident a kind of war
correspondent and between 1992 in Bosnia
and 2004 and Baghdad I pretty much was
in all the predictable places you can
think of the Balkans the Great Lakes
region of Africa Afghanistan Iraq etc
and I'm much too old to do that now but
so it was a sort of and in any case I
wasn't that interested and didn't feel
or to put another way I didn't feel I
had that much to contribute about
military questions that I was already 40
when I started doing this sort of stuff
which is a preposterous age to begin and
I also but but I thought I had something
to say about the humanitarian effects of
war first of all and just in terms of
relief and so I followed I was it kind
of I spent a long time following relief
workers around
in all of these places and many others I
was in Liberia for a bit in Sierra Leone
and and I was in Central America and I
you know I did that for a long time I've
had sort of my say in this book
represents for me to kind of move from
emergency relief humanitarian aid the
effects of war to a more more general
question about development and I and the
book is really about whether the current
mainstream model of development can work
and whether the optimism surrounding it
which I referred to is warranted or not
is is justifiable or not and so I
thought because in the end the starkest
measure of poverty is hunger that I try
to write a book about development and
about the debate over development over
the effort to reduce or end extreme
poverty and to end hunger which are the
stated goals of the major UN agencies of
many NGOs of the great philanthropies
above all the Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation and and they really believe
that this is the first generation in
human history that can end extreme
poverty and extreme and hunger I you
know lay my call a my temperamental
cards on the table I'm sure if you spend
15 years of your one and only life
thinking about war and watching war up
close that you're probably not the most
optimistic of people but I nonetheless
found it very startling as I tried to
begin to think this through and it took
me seven years to write this book and
endless amounts of travel
made all kinds of places rich and poor
alike
well given I was at a loss to understand
the optimism I mean hunger is famine is
along with war the great killer in human
history that's what it is there's been a
famine every year every sorry generation
as far as most experts believe whether
it's the great Indian economist Amartya
Sen or the great Irish economic
historian Carmichael garota the you know
that the estimate is that there probably
was in every society since the beginning
of time or at least since the Neolithic
let's say a great famine every 30 years
so 5,000 years of human history as we
think of it in definable terms the you
know you a famines in every society in
every continent and seemingly with
regularity so why do people think this
was my question as I read through this
literature as I talk to people within
the UN system at these foundations in
hello in many different contexts
why is there so much optimism and I want
to distinguish if you'll indulge me
between optimism and hope I mean
optimism is something that should be
empirically justifiable hope doesn't
have to be you can hope you hope in the
religious sense hope is a is a is a
religious idea among other things and
you can there you don't have to think
that a good outcome is likely to hope
for what but if you say you're
optimistic you're saying something very
different you're actually saying that
you
believe that that a rational person on
empirical grounds should believe things
are going to get better
that's what optimism is the better
doesn't have to be total I'm not you
know I don't want a caricature optimism
as if you'll permit me optimists
caricature pessimism
but I but you know the optimism you
can't just say I'm optimistic because I
want things to be this way or I'm
optimistic because to abandon optimism
is to abandon humanity even though a lot
of people I see I'd suggest have come to
think that as the division between
optimism and hope the distinction excuse
me between optimism and hope has
lessened and people see less and less of
a difference so why was there this
optimism after all one reading of the
world is should one might have thought
lead one to very pessimistic conclusion
and here I'm not talking so much about
wars because actually wars have
diminished over the last hundred years
and while I don't agree with the
psychologist Steven Pinker about
everything in his argument that the
world is getting better and better
he is absolutely right that both the
prevalence and lethality of war has
diminished in last century he's also
right that we've made extraordinary
progress we by which I have said I mean
the human species here not a particular
region or set of powers there's been
great progress made in famine famine is
less lethal than it's ever been
there are all continents in which famine
is now unknown even though
it was known everywhere and in all
civilizations since the beginning of
time the historic home of famine which
is not Africa just by what you read in
the media but is Asia has not seen a
major famine since the the Chinese
famine of 1958 to 62 which was man-made
was not largely speaking a function of
the weather although obviously the
weather played a role but was largely a
function of terrible sanguinary
decisions made by Matsu Tom and his
colleagues in the Chinese People's
Republic of China and you know so you're
already talking about a famine that in
other words could have been averted with
sounder state policies or without the
kind of murderous industrialization
collectivization that the that Mao and
his colleagues decided to impose on the
Chinese people that you know I'm not
diminishing the authority indeed the
great Chinese famine of that period may
be the single most lethal event in human
history
it's said that somewhere around 40
million people died that's that's you
know and that's in one event that's so
you know you you you you could say well
we don't have those anymore and even in
Africa which in some ways is has become
Peru kinds of reasons the last word out
of famine the famines are less lethal
give you an a classic example of this
there was a famine in the air in the
1970s and which killed something like a
quarter of a million people there was
another one a kind of quasi famine
we share in 2005 and only 60,000 people
died now that's a terrible thing the
death of 60,000 people but it's still a
fact that this was a family in the same
place largely the result of the same
climate conditions and confluence of
various disastrous things and yet many
fewer people died because there were
there are technologies to to make to
allow many people particularly the
vulnerable to children to survive that
didn't exist even 30 years ago but
despite this optimism and the world is a
complicated place you know there was a
great German Marxist philosopher of the
1930s Walter Benjamin whom some of you
will certainly know and perhaps some of
you know better than I do but who said
every document of civilization is also a
document of barbarism now the you know
the the record is mixed and it would be
foolish to play cassandra in all of this
but what I wanted to know what I was
trying what I asked myself as I read
these assertions and there come from all
kinds of brilliant people jeffrey sachs
up at Columbia at the Earth Institute
bill gates bill and Bill and Melinda
Gates who are extraordinary people I
happen to be in complete disagreement
with the policies of their philanthropy
but just say that doesn't change the
fact that they are very brilliant and
they've done something very remarkable I
think also very wrong added but we could
talk about that but but it seemed to me
there was just as much reason for
pessimism as optimism for one very
simple reason that's global warming
climate change you know when we're
talking even in these declarations made
and most recently in Paris in the great
in this conference about global warming
you know we're talking about two degrees
Celsius rise in global temperature and
that's if we're lucky people will be
very satisfied if if this can be kept to
two degrees Celsius and yet two degrees
Celsius climate rise is gonna make
vulnerabilities of all sorts in
agriculture
there'll be plants that won't survive at
least in their current form they won't
yields will decline I mean these are not
this is not speculative I mean we we've
run these tests in you know labs and
controlled environments to see what you
know a particular germ plasm of wheat
for example does if you raise the
temperature and we know yields fall they
don't disappear we're not again I'm not
talking about the apocalypse here but it
seemed to me with climate change
anything but resolved why are people so
confident that as it says you drive up
on First Avenue to pass the UN and
you'll see banners that the organization
has put up that say you know poverty
will be eliminated by 2030 I mean there
it's a more sloganeering way of saying
it but that's what the gist of the
argument is so since we don't know
whether we're gonna have two degrees
Celsius if we're lucky or four degrees
if the deal falls through why are people
so optimistic and that was the question
I wanted us and these are pressing
issues I mean if I can do my kind of
global summary there are seven plus
billion people in the world today it is
a dead certainty that there will be nine
option the asteroid coming and killing
us all it is a dead certainty there will
be 9 billion
by 2050 that is not any longer an
alterable fact the question then becomes
will there be 12 billion in 2100 or will
there be actually a stop to this will it
Plateau
have you talked to demographers we're
not the happiest people you know they
they they've been wrong so often that
perhaps they're a little winded but and
most flatlined demographic predictions
have been wrong extrapolating from the
present into the more distant future
have been wrong the classic case of this
is the inventor of demography more or
less the English divine Thomas Malthus
who argued in the early 19th century
that because food production could only
increase arithmetic Li
but population could increase
geometrically that people were going to
starve to death in the fairly near
future and yet that's not what happened
so I mean it's dangerous to talk to
demographers but I don't think even the
most optimistic among us would suggest
that there will be less than 10 billion
people by 2100 so that's an increase in
other words you'll have 1/3 more human
beings on this planet in 85 years than
you do now and a steady increase along
the way to that so how you don't feed
these people and how how is one going to
order the world so that the world
doesn't become a place where again the
poor starve and
at the poor areas and global warming has
been very unfair if you will I mean you
can't call a global phenomenon unfair
because it gives it agency that
obviously a phenomenon cannot have but
nonetheless it will be the poor parts of
the world the Sahelian regions of Africa
parts of the Arab Middle East that are
likely to be most affected in other
words the poorest people are gonna get
the worst of it the people least
resilient toward it are going to get the
worse that their the the situation just
to keep it on food of their agriculture
is going to be the worst affected so why
why all this optimism and as I say the
optimism is pervasive I mean for those
of you who may doubt this I invite you
to go on the websites of any of the
major UN agencies of the World Bank of
the IMF of the major philanthropies of
most of the major relief and development
NGOs in the world and of many
governments and in the global South as
well as in the global North it's not the
optimism is not restricted as a word of
the rich countries of the global north
it is quite widespread there's a an
organization based in Ghana which the
former of which the former Secretary
General of the United Nations Kofi Annan
is now the president called the Alliance
for a green revolution in Africa there
too you're talking about very very smart
people who think things are going to be
steadily better that these disasters are
going to be averted and that in the end
we're actually going to come out with
these goals of ending extreme poverty
and hunger by the way that the
definition of extreme poverty as those
making a dollar 25 a day or less earning
PAMP you know the income of an
individual and they're probably a
billion people like this in the world
today so one in seven of us more or less
why shouldn't if these regions some of
which are also the areas that have not
begun what is conventionally called the
demographic transition that is to say
the fall in birth rates that have has
come in many parts of world look at
Mexico Mexico is a very good example of
a country that in 30 years has gone from
about five kids per family to more or
less replacement level Mexican birth
rates are in freefall and yet you know
again coming back to my skepticism about
what can and can't be predicted I don't
think anyone saw that 30 years ago that
the there was a Roman writer who once
said that he wrote somewhere that he
didn't understand one two soothsayers
met in the road why both didn't burst
out laughing and now but why the
optimism and I again I I freely admit my
bias which is that having spent so much
time in the parts of the world I spent
time in optimism is hard for me it was a
profile of me once years ago in Time
magazine that was actually called mr.
pessimism so you know
be warned full disclosure whatever their
cliche I can deploy on this nonetheless
it did seem to me that with the that I
couldn't I couldn't figure out why
people felt this way and so I tried to
look at the mainstream view which I
attempted to describe and to try to
understand it and then to look at the
critics of that view
most of whom can be some of them are
free-market Hayekian libertarians
there's a very good economic economist
at at NYU Col William easterly who
belongs to that school there's also a
guinean writer called dambisa Moyo who
is associated wrote a famous a book that
was very controversial that Bill Gates
denounced in the most savage terms
called dead aid which is a critique of
development aid in the global South but
the main opposition to them this
mainstream view this view that asserts
we're going to abolish extreme poverty
and hunger by 2030 more or less is is to
be found among what you might sum up as
the members of the anti-globalization
movement of people who think
fundamentally that the problems the
capitalism cannot solve the problems
it's created and that in the end you
know the slogan of the
anti-globalization movement is or one of
its most famous slogans is another world
is possible and that without that other
world which is a political and moral
transformation no amount of
technological wizardry will will will
solve these problems will will make
hungry people have enough to eat or poor
people not be poor anymore
so why do all these smart people I
understand the critique of the
anti-globalization movement and to some
extent I share it and the book I talk
about that at some length in the book
but why do all these smart people think
that hunger is at an end
a will or can be ended why did was Jeff
Sachs written a book called the end of
hunger into poverty excuse me why do
does ban ki-moon the secretary-general
current secretary-general of the United
Nations continually say and in this he's
very firmly seconded by dr. Jim Yong Kim
who's the head of the World Bank at the
moment why do these people by brilliant
people think that we've reached this
genuinely millennial or millenarian
moment this moment unknown in all of
human history I mean short of abolishing
mortality and obviously there are people
in Silicon Valley who think they may be
able to pull that off they're pretty
much of ending poverty is about as
unheard-of as unexpected development
as you can imagine I mean all the major
religious traditions take poverty for
granted the poor will always be with us
the Bible says and their equivalents
views in Buddhism and of course in do
ISM actually tells you that you deserve
your fate that you've obviously done
something terrible the last time out at
least that's a commonplace
interpretation of why people suffer let
you find in India
so what's you know why are they so
optimistic and I think they're a couple
of answers the first is that what all
these people share these very smart
people is to some extent a belief that
we that the great ideological battles of
the past are over or should be over
it's whether explicitly or implicitly
they accept what you might call the
francis fukuyama end of history point of
view and that point of view says it
doesn't say the one was that one mustn't
character it sure it he's also very
smart gun you you Fujiyama said
basically not that bad things wouldn't
no longer happen not that we'd reach the
end of days but that we now knew what a
successful society had to be and that
was a liberal capitalist democracy and
that's what and he said so this is so we
should all agree of course he said lots
of people won't accept this and they'll
be unsuccessful i think that view
permeates the thinking of the mainstream
development world i think basically they
think that we that that the
anti-globalization people attack them
are just crazy we all agree we're all on
the same page we all think we all you
know we we want free markets but also
safeguards we want fair taxation but not
onerous taxation you know we want the
Democratic opponent countability
property rights etc and that this is we
all agree on that
so if you think that then what you think
is there's no political problem so when
the anti-globalization people say but
this isn't a technical problem it's a
political problem
they think there is no political problem
we've solved that and again I'd point
you to Jeffrey Sachs to the UN relevant
UN agencies medical Graziano who runs
the FAO the Food and Agriculture
Organization brazilian guy and certainly
if you go on the website of the Gates
Foundation the Ford Foundation the wrong
about foundation you name it this is
absolutely what people believe so if you
Expo attacks out of the equation then of
course it's much easier to be optimistic
because you just think all these people
are not being constructive I remember
once having a debate with a guy at MIT
who said to me you know what we want
criticism but not the kind you give
because your criticism isn't
constructive and I said to him if that's
really what you mean you're not talking
about criticism you're talking about
brainstorming which is a very different
thing altogether and sometimes it
reminds me I spent up in the late 80s
and very very early 90s I was going back
and forth to Cuba Miami to Havana and
back back and there's a famous speech of
Fidel Castro's it's it's known you can
find it anywhere in you know any lot any
proper oh it's online and many versions
in many languages and it's just called
it's famously called the speech to the
intellectuals and in the end of this
speech he says within the Revolution
everything outside of nothing and I
think that's now the view of the
mainstream development world toward its
critics so what for them is the problem
what for them is what because they're
again these are very smart people they
can they know about global warming -
they're not it's not like the critics
have
Leon intelligence or information on the
contrary if anything so what's the
reason they're optimistic well the
reason they're optimistic beyond the
politics beyond the Fukuyama end of
history part is that a belief that
technology and science will solve every
problem I call this technical check no
utopianism and I believe it's about as
realistic as utopianism which I remind
you means no place but but they believe
and you can find this I mean again I
quote a great many things in the book
but of gates I'm fast enough I did I
used to be actually a contributing
writer to the New York Times Sunday
magazine and I did a long piece on
congregates foundation on their
agriculture programs and followed a guy
called Rajiv Shah who was most recently
Barack Obama's administrator of the US
Agency for International Development
till last year and he and all these
people they say look it's true that we
don't have the solutions now but in 10
years science will provide those answers
even if we don't yet know what they are
and that's why I think it's utopian it's
it's also again an ocean of
problem-solving there are no great moral
questions we already know the answers
according to this mainstream view there
are no great political questions because
we know what the successful polity would
look like so what everything is is a
condiment it's typical that Gates who is
an engineer would think in these
engineering terms which is that problems
are there to be solved not managed
solved not debated brainstormed over its
but you know gates said in a speech and
he very he has his own blog and the
foundation as a blog and its most
revealing I mean it would have been nice
to have had similar insights into the
thoughts of Andrew Carnegie or john d
rockefeller or such people I mean
whatever else you want to say about him
he he's not you know he does put out
what he actually thinks he doesn't
necessarily put out what he thinks about
what Microsoft what taxes Microsoft
should pay but that's perhaps another
conversation for another day but he
basically says in one of his speeches if
I believed that we weren't going to make
progress I'd be pessimistic but I know
we're going to make progress just as we
have in the past and that's the question
the question is are we in effect living
in a different time Bill Gates thinks so
Bill Gates also said he's a he's a
writers dream Bill Gates he said people
live miserably for all of human history
till the Industrial Revolution 250 years
ago since people aren't dumber than they
were 250 years ago and since they were
good politicians before the answer must
be technology the answer that
transformed everything is technology now
he may well be right to some extent
although technology is also what's given
us global warming so you know buyer
beware but the question you need to ask
is does the past condition are the
future now if you know when you look if
you look at CNBC or Fox Business News or
those sorts of stations
they'll be ads for hedge fund I'm sorry
for you
funds and there's always a little moment
at the end after the happy mutual fund
is made their profit where a little
voice comes on you know the small print
says past performance is no guarantee of
future profits now Bill Gates was buying
a company he would not say that because
it's been successful for the last 50
years it will be successful for the next
50 years
on the contrary the smart business
position today is that you know
eventually companies outlive themselves
they're you know it's all about creative
destruction about transformation about
about reimagining everything in other
words transforming companies constantly
so you know you could say why do why do
they think these last 250 years are a
surefire guide to the future when they
wouldn't think that about if they were
making an investment in a corporation I
don't know the answer that no one will
ever answer that question when I ask it
but I insist that it's worth asking
in fact that it must be asked you know
there that the former governor the late
governor of Texas and Richards famously
said of H George HW Bush that he was
born on third base but thought he'd had
a triple and you could say I think that
the question is have we just profited
from these 250 years which i remind you
are the two hundred fifty years when
we've ravaged the planet looking for
fossil fuels for cheap energy
is this a blip or is it the inevitable
shape of things to come that's the
debate and and you know the fate of
hundreds of millions probably billions
of people will be determined by the
answer and I don't I don't have a lot of
answers here but I do have a critique of
the mainstream view and a great worry
that development has been largely taken
over by business and business has its
place it's not a question of you don't
have to be an anti globalization person
of the radical left to say that business
is not everything and yet right now the
rhetoric is the private sector does
everything better than this state the
state is sclerotic and inefficient and
and moribund and all the creative
thinking is in the private sector or in
the academy that's supported by the
private sector if you believe that fair
enough but I think there's plenty of
evidence to argue against that and most
importantly there's the evidence of
paying taxes I mean it's been calculated
that if businesses multinational
corporations paid the taxes that they
pay in the global north in the global
south that Africa for example would be
richer by half a trillion dollars per
annum
if Bill Gates has all this money to
spend it's partly because Microsoft
doesn't have to pay or has chosen not to
pay or has succeeded in not paying what
one might consider its fair share of tax
so if you don't have to pay tax your
profits are gonna be hiring your share
prices higher and if you're Bill Gates
you can there save the world on that
basis or I believe you're on the hinge
of doing so my view is that the state
isn't any of these things but rather
that the state has largely speaking been
murdered or at least undermined by the
present system that in fact what's going
what is going on has been a kind of a
hostile takeover if you want to here's
the b-school term of the state by
business so that you know the state you
know it's it's typical you know poor
people can't afford FedEx unless it's an
emergency
so they you know so the US Postal
Service becomes the thing that serves
poor people and FedEx what serves the
rich does that make FedEx more efficient
than the US Postal Service
that's what FedEx would like you to
think but I'm I think it's quite a
different matter
if you you know if you have if you take
all the bright kids out of public
schools and just leave kids with
difficult home lives and and no
tradition of learning and their families
and then you say the public schools are
a failure surely you've made a mistake
intellectually and morally I think it's
the same mistake that's been made in the
development world and unfortunately I
wish I could sympathize with the
anti-globalization view but since I
don't think for the moment anyway that
those views are going to prevail even
though I agree with a lot of their
analysis I think we're stuck with and
this is the plea I make at the end of
the book and I'll stop after
and hope I've provoked you sufficiently
that that the state needs to be
strengthened again needs to run
development again and there is in the
world of hunger itself a great example
of this the Brazilian government and
it's not a left-right thing because this
was a program started under a neoliberal
President Cardoso and continued under
two socialist presidents Lula and Dilma
it's called zero hunger fullness era and
what the state did was it made at an
absolute priority to radically reduce
hunger in Brazil and it succeeded
there's plenty of poverty in Brazil
Brazil is in many ways a very
problematic place but it's also a place
where in the last thirty years thirty
million people have been brought out of
poverty and where malnutrition rates and
undernutrition rates have really
cratered mexico another society where
people are very negative about it I've
spent a lot of time in Mexico I used to
live in Mexico and I'm appalled of
course by what's happened in terms of
justice in terms of the crime rate but
Mexico has also reduced infant mortality
during the same period with the program
depending on which period you look at it
is called either a report on the ice or
progress and they did it because the
state imposed it it wasn't done without
side money it wasn't done by the private
sector it was done by the state and you
know I'm sorry businessmen can talk all
they like about their good intentions
and then their charitable work they they
often do wonderful things but in the end
they were accountable to their
shareholders and a shareholder is not a
citizen just as a corporation is not a
person which
might be also a conversation for another
day so I think for now you know it's all
very well to imagine that you know
another world is possible
indeed but it's not very likely what is
feasible it seems to me is particularly
the global South where for this state to
reclaim its authority and and and act
and so that's that's where I end the
book it's not a you know great ringing
conclusion it's it's not you know it's
it's not pessimistic but it's certainly
not optimistic either but my analogy the
the English philosopher John Locke said
that reason was a poor candle but it was
all we had and I think the state support
candle and I could probably talk you
know about all the misdemeanors and
felonies and incompetencies of states
all over the world but I still think has
long said of reason you know it's the
only accountable structure we have
because I remind you Bill Gates is
accountable to absolutely no one except
his partner is Melinda Gates
if he finds Jesus tomorrow and decides
to put all his money in the building
churches nothing will stop him he is
capable he can close the foundation any
time he wants now look there's plenty
wrong with democracy and American
democracy given the influence of money
is in particularly parla shape like
nonetheless there's some accountability
and some accountability in a very
difficult time in a world where lots of
good things are happening but lots of
terrible things as well you know it's
than the alternate so I meant to speak a
little bit less but I did what I did and
happy to take some questions I don't
know how long
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
I know it doesn't it's for the oh okay
um first of all thank you for coming out
tonight and sharing this with us
you if I'm understanding you right you
saying that we do have the answers to
these problems correct well the question
was asked to repeat the questions so
I'll do that that we do the gentleman
asks do we have you know do I think we
have the answers I think I know there's
a second part to the rabbi let me start
by answering that I think we have some
of the answers but I think it's very
hubristic the mainstream view is
incredibly hubristic it's a view that
says there are you know there are a set
of answers and once we figure out a way
to apply those answers we're we're home
safe but please continue do you
subscribe to that which view do you
subscribe to and the reason I'm asking
is if you do feel that it is could you
give some specific things that ordinary
people could try to pursue or ask our
representatives to you know encourage
that would be pop hop positive look
there the question was if what can
citizens do to encourage - to try to
bring about a better world first of all
there are lots of groups that doing just
that there's a wonderful organization in
the world of hunger which began as a
Lutheran
organization it's called bread for the
world and run by a guy called David
Beckmann I believe as a minister I'm not
certain no I'm pretty sure and he they
do fantastic popular mobilizations of
people who try for example to change
aspects of US foreign aid and also to
defend policies that in this country are
you know without which a lot more people
would go hungry
I mean think of the WIC program for
those of you familiar with it the WIC
program is constantly under attack and
you know so citizens among other things
can try to persuade their
representatives or try to mobilize to
protect those programs I mean you
abolish WIC you'll have 50% jump and
child malnutrition within a year it's
already bad enough in a country that's
rich
at the beginning but I'm getting the
gist of your your theory and my question
has to do with extremes the blurb said
eliminate extreme poverty so where do we
start in terms of what's the tipping
point when it goes from regular poverty
to extreme poverty and then to famine
and doesn't that factor into the work
that can be done by any organization be
it state or or or private well I mean
extreme poverty is not a is not a
metaphor it's those people who live on
less than a dollar 25 us a day that's
that that's the development definition
of extreme poverty if you bring them
above you bring everybody above that
level then you have you know you have
indeed ended extreme poverty the problem
with the famine model you refer to
famine in on a kind of continuum and I
think there's I think there is a
continuum but the problem is that the
the using famine and the largely
successful fight against famine global
fight or a disease model you know for
example we've been world has been very
successful with certain kinds of
diseases polio is now restricted to a
handful of countries for example river
blindness is largely a thing of the past
etc but the problem with them with that
is it's not at all clear that the
methods used to deal with famine are
applicable to what most global hunger is
which is not famine but chronic
malnutrition and under nutrition that is
to say of people who are either not
getting enough calories or getting
calories that don't provide them with
the nutrients they need and we know
people don't die of this that's not what
happens
what happens though is in aggregate that
the life chances of people were
malnourished between their birth and
their third year of life are very much
diminished there is real
neurological damage for example the
brothers foundation in Toronto has done
a lot of work on this one for the
question regarding